you know who else was funny bill cosby
[Music]
[Applause]
he said all your teeth fell out and your
mouth was just a rotten hole
i haven't known the touch of a woman in
many moons she pointed right at my nose
and then threw up the question is why
would someone want to talk to gina yeah
i still don't know why you dove in
crotch first why am i a pervert oldie
gunk could be yeah doug saved you from
being a mulch butt hoe yo my hands are
covered in butter from making butter
yeah i mean i was constipated for three
days captain holt has no pants on whomp
there it is
these pits are bone dry damn it diane
what are you doing after this
i'm gonna use my musk okay
the bra underneath is insane it is merry
christmas and uh
don't think about the ball
if you love someone you'll remember what
they look like
turtle hump's computer mouse gully's
butt hurts all the time
yeah hi do you sell purple pants that's
a terrible robot boys yep i gorged
myself at that funeral get ready for the
backdraft
[ __ ]
you are really bringing down the vibe at
this funeral i think you're kind of
overdoing it with a manscape oh hey
charles i'll never have a baby with you
because i don't love you and a child's
not going to fix that slam
that was a slam
let's pound it
i out not a good detective coming strong
man just three people with pants on
having a normal conversation gotta cover
up them fangs yeah can i play with your
laser pointer my sasquatch
wait
are we having
fine dude
that's right famine and deep ball these
bands
that flat ass is perched right on top of
my ute
i am going to scooch you don't tell me
when to scooch
right time to put some daddy into my
mommy
the futility of lighting candles only to
blow them out immediately is just one
reason i find children's birthday
parties impractical jake why don't you
just do the right thing and jump out a
window coat coat jacket coat oh that's
so yucky i get off on violence oh my god
that's the most intimate thing you can
do to a lover with your fingers
i'm sorry don't stab me let us walk in
this direction
[Music]
i'll do anything to perk up my little
man yo
mamma mia that's a bloody pizza pie
smosh s'mores
there has been a jail break and the
mafia is at it again curse my beautiful
bubble butt
jake the hero abs of steel shalalala
[Music]
i wasn't injured i was lightly stabbed
looks like you and i are in a good
old-fashioned suck-off
straight up living that slug life y'all
the boobs
michael buble i'm really into rented
clothes i love how many butts have been
in them
[Music]
craig craig knight a funky fun i already
told you i'm not go go dancing i hope
you get hit by a truck and a dog takes a
dump on your face ah thong why are you
wearing a thong this is my juicier duct
i will treasure this painting of a rock
for all times uh-oh your girl knows
about the oozebacks hmm
loose granola if everyone loved him the
dumb jerk r.i.p
no no no no strangled mangled hung i.e
dangle we are vibing
[Music]
thanks dad
i stepped on my omelette this morning is
there any way i can borrow 430 thousand
dollars too late spice boy train has
left the station
[Music]
i am feeling trepidation as a prospect
of a parentless existence great who are
we killing one pound
two and seven not now brian i am wagging
brenda
you